hello welcome to this video playing raw
rock home motion now we'll win this game
just decided to windows after three
consecutive losses I really need to win
now especially all those losses came
from decent positions or winning
positions and mostly okay that d 6 line
a lesson line with e for hear that
sometimes i think is played and didn't
do that and i think someone played this
eve or against me
ok so where are you going just a four
year
maybe you can take with a pawn them no
check
okay get the key to see two and then go
for g3 it was my idea that g3 move check
okay I can just take f1 now I guess
Queen B 6 is just completely useless
check so he tries to open the position
up somehow with b5 stuff okay maybe it
would be 144 Queen 843 for King hmm yeah
yeah I mean objectively this is not
enough for black and it's pretty obvious
but still with no with with this time
you never know and what kind of nonsense
might happen how many points are map
three pawns
check em OOP do one again I don't see
any threats I'm just too bad
simply see no threats at all
mm I'm terribly bad at defending a king
position however you have to have to
admit that I have a hot tub to see it
taking a chance against me okay here at
least I know what would move i have to
play Jack so I'm getting checkmated
after all no I can give this now let's
draw or something I mean I have to take
check that much is clear but now he's
got no check right nice don't know check
Queen a for now is the only check left
look b3 Queen a [ __ ] be 224 Queen big
one Kim be one should be enough
soon
III root B 3 and then he's checking me
again I'd get that's annoying but I can
take a 3 then check check check that
that's it that's really it black resigns
yeah Bishop see to finally will cover
everything Jeff strange game so he upon
Texas of course interesting clearing the
square that potentially very good for
black I was only thinking that maybe a
quick g3 could I could tell but it looks
pretty good for black their oppression
played that okay it can of course take
with a night that's not a check not a
mistake I was surprised that he didn't
that he just played Bishop 27 here like
that g3 was a pretty clear idea and yeah
i mean i don't think the engine is
completely unimpressed and think this is
just a slight advantage for white but
it's not easy to play for a human player
just open up the age file like that
without having any obvious counterplay
check ok when their queen d 8 and take
the pawn a fine engine wants to go look
a b-1 so i'm i'm defending this as well
up to him and be five
I have to take and see form I have to
take Roxy age now ok I went back quindi
for is even stronger yeah okay it's
something that I could have seen just
centralizing and yeah makes an awful lot
of sense ok so this this and I just kept
and check everything here looks III rock
b1 b6 check check check I'm just
checking with with the computer and just
it was ok didn't check didn't bungle it
up at one point that at any point I
really am really good at that so glad to
yeah not suffered the same fate again
okay thanks for watching